vingt-cinq mille participants attendus à
la 42e édition de paris versailles et de
lieux emblématiques la tour eiffel au
départ et le château de versailles à
l'arrivée un parcours qui reste
inchangée depuis 1975 pour ce grand
classique de la rentrée sportive
à l'époque les courses sur route
n'existait pas du tout il y avait très
peu de courses sur route
et puis il ya eu de faits de course à
pied je dirais qu'ils ont eu cette idée
de rejoindre de monuments emblématiques
dans la région parisienne ce qui était
une bête caractéristique c'est depuis de
44 ans n'a jamais changé de parcours
puisque forcément des deux monuments
seront toujours là et c'est vraiment
très emblématique de pouvoir partir de
serre la torre fred est d'arriver ici
face au château de versailles le tracé
de 16 km conduira les participants au
travers d'issy les moulineaux de la
forêt de meudon ou encore de la route
royale à chaville principale difficulté
les dénivelés et 2 km de côtes attendent
les coureurs il ya un tiers de plats à
paris pour bien s'échauffer du départ
jusqu'à le bas de la côte de moudon
depuis la fameuse côte de moudon qui du
fait deux kilomètres
j'ai suivi de plusieurs petites bosses
et une grande descente et ensuite encore
une grande côte à viroflay
et puis viroflay 7/13 kg mais non via
trois derniers kilomètres qui sont
légèrement difficile aussi parce que
c'est un plat montant surtout ici sur
versailles
sur la ligne paris qui est très large et
donc on n'a pas l'impression des
distances et puis surtout dès qu'il ya
un peu de vent toujours de face premier
départ à 10 heures pour une arrivée à
versailles en fin de matinée grosse
logistique sur la course mille sept cent
cinquante bénévoles seront mobilisés sur
ce 42e paris versailles